we all know William Shakespeare the most
famous author of all time
writer of 37 plays 154 sonnets several
epic poems and why we are here today but
what if I told you
Shakespeare never wrote a single word
well anonymous is my new movie who made
I was like 10 years in the making like
10 years ago I like kind of read a
script called soul of the age and you
know I immediately fell in love with it
you know read everything about the
subject matter and then in like three or
four years you know like kind of tried
to make this work better together if the
writer and then we needed like six years
to get it made anonymous is an
Elizabethan thriller set against the
backdrop of the Shakespeare authorship
question meaning who wrote the plays of
William Shakespeare that we now call the
plays of William Shakespeare this is
like a pretty much you know like an
alternative story of what could have
happened you know that because I I
believe you know that a man from
Stratford was not the true author so who
wrote it and this gives you one
explanation who could have written it
it's like a theory it's like kind of not
proven but it's also not proven that the
man from Stratford wrote it so it's like
I think a very valuable you know to make
a movie about that and there will be a
lot of like noise from the literary
departments you know all over America
and the world there's like a literate
establishment naturally who doesn't want
to have this question even asked because
there's a huge industry going on you
know if the man from Stratford there's a
couple of books you know around you know
which like opened my eyes you know which
I thought you know they were I believe
these people much more because they have
nothing to lose you know all these like
kind of scholars you know which like
kind of tell you in their books what
like I really happened they all have
something to lose because they have to
lose you know their reputation their
whole lives work and like two or three
passes almost
so you have to be very careful what
these people write because what's known
about William Shakespeare is that he was
you know a moneylender he was a theatre
you know like play broker a part owner
of the globe and at the end he retired
you know to like kind of strike for the
navin you know to never ride again they
say and you know and there he was like
accused of like having hoarding grain in
the time of famine which is like kinda
shows he was like not the nicest
character the reason why it took two
hundred years for people to start
questioning the authorship is really
twofold one Shakespeare wasn't
Shakespeare but we call Shakespeare the
greatest playwright of all time really
until the seventeen hundreds late 1700s
early 1800s for a lot of the 17th
century he wasn't even really well known
and so it took a while for the history
to catch up and the question of
authorship to catch up with his
popularity
you